dovevo avere circa sette anni la prima
volta che ho pensato a come si cambia il
mondo ma soprattutto pensato maki maki o
cambia il mondo e la risposta ma hanno
aiutato a capirla i giovani imprenditori
sociali e chi sono gli imprenditori
sociali sono delle persone che hanno
un'idea e la trasformano in un bene un
servizio da vendere sul mercato come
ogni imprenditore vogliono fare dei
profitti però tendono a reinvestire i
propri profitti per il bene comune
anzi di più strutturano la propria
impresa attorno all'impatto sociale che
il bene o servizio a su un dato
territorio e quindi cercando di
collegare continuamente la propria
ambizione personale a quello che è
l'impatto in una comunità la comunità in
cui vivono
ok gli imprenditori sociali cambiano il
mondo e hanno aiutato a capirlo a me
ovvero due minuti e costruiamo assieme
la risposta il mio colore e il blu
quando avevo sette anni il blu che mi
piaceva di più era quello della mia
squadra del cuore
vent'anni dopo dal 2008 il blu che mi
appassiona e quello delle nazioni unite
e da quando ho cominciato a lavorare per
le nazioni unite
mi sono chiesto sempre più
insistentemente ma chi è che non cambia
il mondo allora alle nazioni unite il
momento topico è la terza settimana di
settembre bandiera blu assemblea
generale e 30 40 50 capi di stato e di
governo che si trovano proprio lì
era sicuro ti tremano un po le gambe ti
sembra davvero che stia cambiando il
mondo ci ho passato tre anni
però mi mancava qualcosa allora ho
lasciato le nazioni unite per un attimo
e sono stato in tunisia in egitto in
libia e ho cercato la risposta tra quei
giovani che chiedevano anzi urlavano la
loro richiesta al loro desiderio di
cambiamento nella cosiddetta primavera
araba
ho trovato l'energia l'entusiasmo anche
la follia
però mi mancava ancora la risposta
allora ho solo chiuso gli occhi
l'ho sognato colori aperti e ho
continuato a sognare e mi sono guardato
addosso
così giusto molto concretamente alle
cose che aveva le scarpe i pantaloni la
maglietta chiuso per andare a correre la
sciarpa con cui mi copro ma anche la
sedia su cui mi siedo oppure l'app del
mio telefonino che uso oppure è la
musica che ascolto
e ho cominciato a sognare che
all'interno di ognuno di questi oggetti
ci fosse incorporato un sogno anzi ho
immaginato che ognuno di questi oggetti
fosse il simbolo di un cambiamento
sociale positivo di un riscatto di una
speranza di futuro anziché proprio
questi oggetti fossero la costruzione di
futuro cioè per esempio guarda un po
calze colorate mi sono immaginato se
queste calze colorate non fossero il
simbolo dell'armonia tra razze e culture
diverse oppure se questi pantaloni non
fossero prodotti da un'azienda che
reinveste gli utili per ricomporre un
conflitto che ha fatto migliaia di morti
oppure se questa maglietta non fosse il
disegno o le speranze le ambizioni di
bambini di rifugiati
oppure ancora se questa sedia o questo
sgabello non fossero fatti con tutto con
legno di riciclo da persone che
normalmente sono fuori dal mercato del
lavoro
oppure ancora se le app che uso sul mio
telefonino non fossero prodotte da una
cooperativa che green and social oppure
infine se la musica che ascolto non
fosse prodotta da una casa discografica
israelo palestinese in cui la musica
stessa sia simbolo di fraternità
state tranquilli questi sono solo sogni
questi sono oggetti e come ogni oggetto
servono non serve o forse no perché
queste calze sono prodotte da andrà in
austria e questi colori rappresentano
davvero l'armonia tra razze e culture
diverse perché per andrà lo ha vissuto
sulla propria pelle
lei che è stata oggetto di
discriminazioni a causa della sua
nazionalità e pe drag in bosnia
erzegovina fa moda etica e impiega i
figli di quelli che si sono fatti la
guerra a srebrenica e dintorni e said in
giordania vendere le magliette dei
bambini dei rifugiati palestinesi che si
trovano nei campi e e pisana pisana
produce mobili arredamento tutto fatto
con legno di riciclo impiegando persone
che probabilmente senza di lei non
troverebbero lavoro oppure danilo in
sicilia cui produce delle app che creano
coscienza ambientale e coscienza sociale
positiva e infine ba tel
ba tel ma anche crudo sarà sono
israeliani e palestinesi
vengono da una famiglia di coloni dal
cuore di israele e dalla striscia di
gaza e spesso non riescono neanche a
uscire dalla striscia di gaza però
alcuni di loro sono amici gli uni con
gli altri e producono musica servizi
vestiti e ritengono che uno dei modi di
risolvere il conflitto sia tramite i
prodotti che fanno
insomma dietro ognuno di questi prodotti
c'è un'idea di cambiamento un sogno ma
non qualcosa di astratto di idealista ma
qualcosa di concreto ci tocca
fisicamente e i produttori sono
imprenditori
allora come ogni imprenditore il loro
sogno è di diventare come steve jobs
jack ma elon musk mark zuckerberg
tutti i modelli maschili è vero perché
perché a livello globale tra gli
imprenditori c'è una imprenditrice donna
ogni tre imprenditori uomini tra gli
imprenditori sociali sempre a livello
globale sono il 45 per cento donne e il
55 per cento uomini quindi quasi metà e
metà va bene sulla parità ci siamo ma i
profitti è il bello è che anche i
profitti sembrano andare a favore delle
imprese sociali
lo dico io no non lo dico io lo dicono
gli studi della commissione europea che
ha fatto uno studio su tutti i 28 i
paesi dell'unione e ha visto che in quei
paesi dove c'è una legislazione per
l'imprenditoria sociale
le imprese che hanno una missione
sociale tendono ad avere un fatturato
fino al 10 per cento più grande rispetto
alle imprese che non ce l'hanno
insomma guadagnano e cambiano il mondo
sono imprenditori e sociali sociali e
imprenditori
allora dal 2012 ho deciso che per
svolgere il mio ruolo all'interno delle
nazioni unite io dovevo allearmi con
loro
in primo luogo dovevo imparare da loro e
poi dovevo portare le loro soluzioni
sull'immigrazione e disuguaglianze
la disoccupazione giovanile l'ambiente
l'educazione l'estremismo violento
tutte queste soluzioni beh vi ricordate
quelle persone della terza settimana di
settembre
ecco a loro
e chiedere quindi ai governanti di
adattare la legislazione la fiscalità
l'ecosistema per far sì che gli
imprenditori sociali possano operare ma
perché perché bene bene però soprattutto
perché conviene economicamente però
questa non è solo una storia per
governanti perché certo la legislazione
la fiscalità lasko sistema sono belle
cose però non è che ci fanno sognare è
un sogno e reale quando appartieni a
tante persone e oppure quando è lo
spirito lo spirito di qualcosa e
l'imprenditoria sociale è lo spirito è
lo spirito di una generazione anzi di
più di una generazione
volete i numeri l'indotto
dell'imprenditoria sociale nel mondo
impiega 40 milioni di persone e il
fatturato delle imprese sociali è simile
a quello di un paese come l'italia
però vedo che qua c'è ancora qualcuno
che non è convinto e va bene allora per
convincersi generalmente bisogna toccare
al portafoglio
e allora immaginiamo che qualche anno fa
poi avesse avuto dei soldi da investire
dove li avreste investiti mutui subprime
non una grande idea bitcoin è ben non
cattiva oppure oppure nel mercato
dell'impact investing che cos'è il
mercato dell'impianto investing di
mercato dell'impatto investing sono
quegli investitori che decidono di
puntare il proprio capitale sulle
imprese sociali negli ultimi 15 anni il
mercato dell'import investing è
cresciuto di dieci volte tanto quindi se
l'imprenditoria sociale fosse un paese
si darebbe al tavolo del g8
se fosse una foresta sarebbe un polmone
verde
è tutto oro no perché la foresta c'è
sotto questa foresta cioè come una
miniera sotterranea e all'interno della
miniera c'è dell'oro però non luccica
abbastanza le soluzioni degli
imprenditori sociali non scalano
abbastanza allora un po ogni volta che
ci metteremo addosso un oggetto qualcosa
che porteremo con noi che ci serve
lo sceglieremo perché è bello perché è
utile e sarebbe ancora più interessante
se oltre a essere bello utile ci
comunicasse la storia il sogno che ci
sta dietro ogni volta che indossiamo
perché la foresta degli imprenditori
sociali
cresce comunque il trend è questo e per
avventurarsi all'interno della foresta è
semplice comincia oggi dal prossimo
oggetto o dal prossimo acquisto
grazie
[Applauso]